wir bei youtube wissen es der film
entsteht im kopf und dazu gibt es auch
den passenden song und klar von andreas
bourani nur in meinem kopf heißt und als
ich ihn es ist glaube ich schon zwei
monate her ist das erste mal im asphalt
club in berlin gehört habe dachte ich
mir das wird ein hammer und der mutter
klicks und ist es normal geworden wenn
man jetzt das radio einschaltet
und also ist es zeit er muss zur box und
kommen andreas bourani und er hat
zugesagt und ihr könnt eure fragen
stellen wie immer und ich sag jetzt mal
wieder soweit einfallsreich es ist am
besten eine video frage zu stellen lässt
den info text und dann habt ihr die
besten chancen rampe kommen ich bin
gespannt er ist gespannt und überhaupt
das alles spannend